hello everyone hope you guys are okay
and welcome to today's session and
thanks so much for registering
um
today we're gonna we will we'll talk
about what is github co-pilot and how to
add a similar machine learning
capabilities to your application
it's going to be a 30 minutes long
session
today i'm joined by two other speakers
conor and jeff so
you guys might introduce yourself maybe
let's start with canal
hey everybody thanks for joining uh i'm
kunal i'm a machine learning engineer at
hugging face and today i'm going to be
demoing some of the uh the cool
capabilities you can achieve with our
inference api as well as more
practically how to use them
jeff go ahead
hi everyone i'm i'm jeff i'm on the
product team at hugging face
i work on making all that great science
available to as many people and
companies as possible
and i'm ferdinand and i am doing a deep
level marketing at a gig phase
and i'll be
moderating the station today
um so to give you a rough agenda of what
we're gonna do today i will start by
discovering what is gate.copilot and we
will explain how you can recreate it
using the inference api from urging face
and then canal will show you how to
a few demos and
do some live cutting
uh you guys should stay until the end
because there is a gift for all you all
of you at the end of the sessions
and if you have any questions for us
during the session uh feel free to ask
them uh
under the question panel
we will try to get back to you during
the q a session at the end or at least
within the next day and you'll get
access to the mat all the material that
we showed today so there is no need to
take notes or
register anything um
this is recorded and you you'll get a
replay very soon
and that's it pretty much let's just
write in a canal if you want to start
uh sorry i think jeff is going to start
with oh it was jeff sorry
of course yeah i'd love to provide some
context i mean uh here the the the main
part is uh connell is going to show you
how to do things uh but in this first
part i want to tell you uh why uh why
it's important and and how you're able
to do all these things yourself
but first let's take a step back um the
goal here is to
show you
how
you can use
all the great science and models that
hugging face provides
to create amazing experiences like
github co-pilot and what is github
co-pilot it's a new service uh that was
launched recently
by github that really captured the
attention of the developer community
it's an ai code assistant
that uses all the context within your
code project to make suggestions to you
it makes suggestions to you to finish a
line of code to complete a full
function based on the documentation or
to create documentation based on the
code that you've written it's a really
really cool tool
that
i invite you to check out at the core
under the hood is a transformer model
and what is a transformer model it's
this new generation of machine learning
that created new capabilities to do
things like summariesing summarizing
texts creating text turning images into
text there's a million uh use cases for
this new generation of models
transformers
and i'll show you how
you can find them explore them and use
them but
if you wanted to create your own github
copilot
one issue is that the transformer model
which was built by open ai it's called
codex
this transformer model unfortunately is
not open source um so i will show you
how you can use open source model
models to create your own experiences
like github
co-pilot
um so to tell you about this let me give
you a few um a few pieces of information
about a hugging face hugging face is the
home of transformers we talked about
open ai codex model the transformer
model that is the heart the engine
behind github co-pilot well hugging face
is the home of all transformers in fact
if you go to our website on
hf dot co hugging face dot co you will
find over 10 000 transformers models
it's kind of like the app store but for
uh four state of the art models these
transformer models and whether you're
like you're looking to
create an app uh that deals with legal
documents or that wants to classify
images that wants to transcribe a
conversation an audio conversation into
text there's a model for that there's a
transformer for that and you can find
all of those on hugging face at hf.co
what's different though is that all of
these models they're open source
they're provided and hosted for free for
you to access to try to test to download
through our open source and through our
machine learning platform
um what our mission our mission is to
democratize machine learning
this new era of science uh that is
evolving so fast that it's hard for
companies to keep pace with it and
that's what we do that's why we do it
through our open source that's what we
do through our products
and we do this by focusing on community
and we do this by focusing on
efficiency making all these things work
as fast as possible
and that has led uh some amazing uh
adoption uh of here our transformer open
source library that is about to reach 50
000 github stars um
which is like in just a couple of years
i think unprecedented for
ai or machine learning
in terms of open source adoption
um there is one trend behind all this
which is um since the introduction of
the initial transformer model uh the
size of those models has been growing
exponentially it every six months sort
of doubles in size uh this trend was
true a couple years ago it is still true
now that open uh open ai gpt 3 with 170
billion characters exist and that
creates a lot of challenges for machine
learning engineers for companies to
adopt these things and put them in their
own apps it's uh it's very complicated
because these models are large these
models are complex they require special
hardware they require special skill to
distill them into something that works
in production and so that's why
the inference api which you'll find on
our website again hf dot co is the
perfect tool for you to take all of
these free open source models and use
them directly in your apps without
having to dive into what kind of
architecture machine learning uh things
you need to use it is super fast we
optimized all of our models so you can
up to 100x speed up to what you would
get if you were trying to do this
yourself it's built to be scalable
so as your usage grow will be able to
support your uh your project through our
infrastructure
and it's completely secure uh through uh
through our https and other features
like logless we can offer
so what can you do with these
state-of-the-art transformer models and
the inference api to power your own
application that's what squinal is going
to show you now in a short demo thanks a
lot
all right guys thanks jeff for that
intro um yeah so like like jeff
mentioned before we get into kind of
more of the the practical how to use
this this api um to leverage these
really powerful machine learning models
the first thing we're gonna do uh is
actually go through our actual website
to give you guys a flavor of the
capabilities um you can find within
within our api so let me share my screen
real quick uh and hopefully you guys
will be able to see this
there we go i think we should be good to
go yeah so you guys might have seen this
on on one of jeff's slides this is kind
of our model hub where you can access
over 12 000 plus uh public models you
see a little bit more here because i'm
you know special in the private
organization of hugging face but 12 000
plus models um for a vi a wide variety
of tasks and you can get a flavor for
some of the things that are uh possible
within our api and filter them uh within
this page as well um but i'm going to
start off kind of a common task we we
see on our end of usage which is
uh summarization of documents um and so
i'm just going to choose based on our
most popular models um just an example
to show you guys here and uh let's let's
go grab a non-controversial a news
article to summarize for you guys to
show you an example of kind of what you
can achieve so uh let's go with maybe
robin hood ipo i think is is a news a
news article that's coming out soon uh
yeah this looks good um
so yeah you can think of you know the
the wide variety of of cases even just
for within summarization um kind of what
you can achieve you know it could be
financial documents could be news
articles like this one could be emails
um pretty much whatever you can think of
um and this is just within the
summarization task one of one of many so
here we go uh we can demo within the
actual api website um the usage of this
model
oh no we got audio from the robin hood
okay there we go we can see a quick a
quick summary here and you can see how
powerful and easy this is to use within
our wet our widgets um and also how
simple it is for you to go and try out
models before actually leveraging our
api
um so not only
do does the hugging face api support you
know simple nlp nlp meaning um
text-based tasks like this one um but
the feel of machine learning you know
advances very very rapidly and uh at
hugging face we do our best to keep up
with that so another popular model uh
many of you may have heard of is called
gpt-3 which is actually the backbone of
what github co-pilot is made out of um
and another thing that gpt-3 has
popularized is this concept called few
shot learning
and let me explain that a little bit
fuchsian learning is essentially
getting a model uh to do a task you care
about without having to train it
specifically for that task and this is
very interesting for domains with like
less data in them so let me show you an
example of what that could look like in
practice um so this model has not been
trained uh to do what i'll show you
which is sentiment analysis you know is
this a positive negative or neutral text
but if i show this model a few examples
of what i'd like it to achieve meaning
uh i'll show it a couple of tweet
examples and associated labels and we
can go through that here as an example
like here's a tweet check out oh sorry
let me go to the beginning of this i
hate when my uh phone battery dies and
the sentiment of that is
negative uh again another example tweet
my day has been great sentiment positive
i give it a few of these examples and
then i ask it
at the end to say check out this awesome
video and i don't give it the sentiment
let's see what the model can do
so we run it real quickly and we can see
that with few shot learning without
explicitly being trained on a specific
task of sentiment analysis
that gpt3 is still capable of producing
the correct label for this model or for
this task sorry
so yeah i mentioned that the field of
machine learning you know moves very
rapidly and natural language processing
has has advanced you know very
significantly in recent years but you
know the backbone models transformers
which jeff had talked about a little bit
um have rapidly found their ways into
other modalities or other other fields
of machine learning as well um and so
hugging face we tried to move as quickly
as possible with that as well and so
i'm going to show you uh another
possible
use
and the power of use of that you can
have with this library
or with this api and so the example i'm
going to give you here is speech
recognition is just you know recognizing
speech and converting it to text
it's very useful for meeting
transcription and there's many other use
cases you can think of so
what i'm going to do here is actually
record myself speaking and hopefully the
model will uh will transcribe it
properly
look how simple speech recognition can
be
let's let's make sure we got that right
hopefully you guys can hear that too and
let's transcribe it let's see what we
get
and there we go it's as simple as that
now you know we we also mentioned you
know that that the uh transformers have
made their way into you know a bunch of
different fields we've done speech
recognition and speech in general why
not vision as well right
so another quick example before we move
on to the the live coding section um
let's do some some image classification
right and uh
let's maybe what's what's a simple
example we could do here maybe maybe
let's let's look for airplanes on uh
on google
do a quick download of this guy
all right we got that and let's uh let's
see let's see what this guy's capable of
there we go it's classified as an
airliner and
now what's very exciting is we're going
to move on to the live coding demo
portion of the of this and
we'll show you just how simple it is to
actually leverage these these models
that i've shown you um in practice and
you know i've only really shown you four
models here um kind of across a few of
the modalities and tasks that we that we
handle but
with 12 000 plus models available on our
inference api i hope you can understand
the immense amount of possibilities and
machine learning power you can bring to
the software that you guys develop
um so yeah with that let's let's move on
to
the live coding portion of this demo um
so
what i'm going to do uh during this demo
is essentially
go through creating a vs code extension
that's capable of
taking python code you've written and
generating a comment describing that
python code um
and so
all the code we go through today will be
available on github and we'll send the
link out shortly after
um after this webinar today uh and
before we jump into it i also want to
note that the vs code portion of this
demo is closely based on a youtube video
from an author called nathan cooper
we'll also send that video out in our
github uh link
as well shortly after this um but yeah
using this vs code extension we're going
to use the power of our inference api to
to leverage a documentation generator um
so with that let's let's get started um
we're going to get started by uh
an installation of a
that is uh helpful for creating new vs
code extensions um it's called yo code
uh and so the command we run for this is
just you know using npm package manager
install yo code um i'm not actually
gonna install this right now because it
takes a while i've already pre-done this
so we can save a little bit of time but
this is the first command you would run
um and with that let's let's actually
run uh yo code to
uh start
the start uh this this vx code project
there we go and it's gonna ask me a
series of questions just to create a you
know format for
for this project um and we're going to
do it in typescript
uh and let's name this uh you know
good good coding practices let's give it
a good name uh doc generator for
documentation generator we'll use the
default identifier for this uh bad
coding practice let's let's not give it
a description for the sake of brevity uh
here's the github repo so that you guys
will have access to it after
and let's just use npm and there we go
now it's creating our package uh that we
will use
and
hopefully this part doesn't take too
long there we go all right and let's uh
let's get started so i'm going to go
into the
directory it just created
and i'm going to launch vs code so we
can start developing and testing this
this command
there we go and hopefully this is all
showing up on my screen as well
all right so there's going to be really
two files we work with here um one is
package.json i'm sure a lot of you are
familiar with is going to handle our
dependencies but most importantly our
entry points um to this file and how we
actually call this command um and the
other file we're going to work with
actually
defines the functionality um from the
entry point so you can see that we are
registering the actual command here and
executing the code
which is triggered by the entry point
defined in package.json
so the first thing we're going to do is
you know obviously test uh like every
good programmer started out the the
hello world function that's already
defined here
and basically the idea is that um
with uh when calling the command it'll
just print hello world um i just started
the test debug window so hopefully this
will show up there we go
and yeah let's just test this command
hello world
boom you can see in the bottom right
that works all right so so far so good
um
right so now what we're gonna do is uh
since we wanna be able to highlight uh
our python code we write and uh have a
document documentation generated based
off that code the first thing we need to
do is define an entry point um that
allows us to do this so i'm going to add
a command here
that allows us to do that so
i'm going to access the menus
which is you know this is a menu
and
basically
i'm going to add a few configurations
here so that
it actually knows the window we're using
when it should be triggered um
etc so you know we want we want to grab
a selection of code we've written
um
so that we can actually you know use
that code to pass to our model and
generate documentation based off of
we have to tell it the command we
actually want it to run so right now
that's
[Music]
just what's defined in the extensions
code right now
it's just the hello world function
and uh finally we want to uh give it the
group name so that is just the group is
where it's going to show up within this
menu and i'm going to put it in the cut
copy paste as it's it's kind of like a
tool functionality
um
so here we go
all right
so this should work uh for allowing that
command actually show up and so that we
can test that we're actually grabbing a
selection of of kind of what we've typed
out in our a final use case that'll be
the actual code we've written um let's
just add a quick test here to make sure
that uh we're actually getting the
correct selection um
so what we're gonna do is um
we are going to first you know get the
actual editor window we're within
there we go
and uh do a quick check to make sure you
know editor hasn't been exited out of or
anything like that
um fail fast good coding practices we
love that right um then we're going to
get the actual document that this editor
is accessing
we can access the text within it and use
that as our code we're going to comment
um
then we're going to get the actually
currently selected code
and
[Music]
and using this selection um we actually
have to access the text from the
document um
indexed by the selection so we're we're
going to use this function uh get text
using the selection um from this
document and now
this text should actually be whatever
the selected code is so let's let's uh
prints out instead of you know hello
world uh let's get a little bit more
advanced here and print out the actual
text we selected selected so uh with
that let me let me test out this
functionality real quick
save this we're gonna go back to our
test window
um refresh it
and uh let's hope this works
all right
we don't need this
testing one two three
and hopefully we'll see this pop up in
the menu oh maybe i didn't refresh it
make sure we save this properly
all right testing one two three
select you select you
and hello world there it showed up and
we got testing one two three okay so
that capability is working just fine um
all right so now we actually want to get
through um
sending our or actually leveraging our
inference api this is this is really
what we care about and
this will show you how simple it is
because this really is you know a small
portion of actually creating this vs
code extension um so to do so i'm
actually going to install another thing
from npm that allows us to make post
requests to this api i'm sure this is
something that a lot of you are familiar
with as well um but we're just gonna npm
install um
actions which is the library we're gonna
use to send uh api requests um hopefully
this doesn't take too long perfect all
right
and we're gonna add this as a dependency
to our
code um so import actios from
axios
all right
and the final thing that i need to do
because i don't want any sneaky people
here to steal my api
is i am going to actually copy over
um
copy over my api key from a different
file i have uh let's make sure we've got
this correctly
there it is
oops
okay there we go we will try not to show
off that uh that key
um all right so then uh last thing i'm
gonna do yeah is add add my api key here
um so
let's do
that
and uh i'll repeat this as an example
that you can you can actually reference
um within within the github repo we send
out so that you can see what what
formatting oh
cannot find module api
key well we can fix that towards the end
anyway um great so so with that api key
what we're actually going to do now is
is call this api and uh
implement the
the necessary function for you know
generating this comment and inserting it
to your vs code um so with that what
we're gonna do is
generate the documentation so we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna
call the api and and in the callback
edit the actual document we are
currently working on um so to do this
what we're going to do is first um
setup the api url i'm just going to copy
and paste this for brevity but it is a
model that is trained to generate
documentation based on code you've seen
um so we're hitting our api and this is
the specific model we are going to be
using today um again you'll be able to
reference this in the github repo we
send out
um and then we are gonna actually uh
define the payload we're gonna send to
this model um and so
this is gonna be simple enough it is
literally just gonna be the
text that we we grabbed earlier and we
tested that this works um so we're gonna
select the text and send that over to
our model through our api
to be a little more advanced
let's specify we want to use uh
accelerated hardware so that our you
know response is faster
so we'll set use gpu to true
there we go so that's everything we need
to use to leverage the everything we
need to use the leverage the api and so
now let's actually send uh this post
request
and we'll send this to obviously the api
url
we'll send a json
object of the payload we just defined
oopsie there we go
all right and then um we will pass the
header so that it's actually using uh
the api key that i had specified in that
other file i copied over so that's the
request and that's all it takes to
leverage uh to actually send the data
over to our api and now we are going to
to uh
give it a callback function for actually
using the response of the api to uh
modify and and provide the documentation
um for the selected code
i'll try to hurry up here as i know
we're a little short on time
so
right here all i'm doing is uh creating
an edit builder this will actually be
what goes into our document
our selection and um add the
documentation um that our model has
generated um so this is all you know vs
code extension stuff
and we want to create our code at the
start of the code we've selected um
that's you know we'll add the comment
above the code we've written um you know
python code comment with uh with the
pound sign
and then to leverage our api we're going
to take our response the data from our
response um and
the actual um
documentation generated from the model
there we go and a new line just for a
good measure
and
semicolons
we don't need this anymore as this
should work and finally for uh for other
good measure we are going to
um change our command from hello world
to uh generate comment
all right now i think we've got one
little bug here that we have to fix is
uh
why my api key is not being picked up
let's see
what are we getting here
not really sure what is going on here oh
oh i guess let's try uh let's try saving
it and running it here
another test testing
oh we're not even getting our command
anymore
generate comment or at least the name
change worked
um
let's check one more time to make sure
we didn't do anything crazy here
i'm gonna copy over my api key one more
time
we've got our api
oh i think it's that's what it's doing
it's copying over something incorrectly
when i
call this other command
all right one more time
go
to demo effect ferdinand saying
it always never works okay well
just so we can get this done i guess we
will maybe show you my api key um
for the sake of time
we can we'll change this later so
don't go using my api key
please
there we go
all right and so we'll just define some
headers here that as well
boom
all right
let's get around that
all right let's see what we can do now
all right
just to test it or i guess i guess let's
test it with some code huh
let's uh let's define a fibonacci
sequence generator
and oh let's make sure this is a python
code too
how can we eat this guy python boom
that way i get a little
little boost from vs code as well
oh
it started with python
all right and so let's just quickly get
through this guy
and show you what we can do
all right so this should generate uh
this should be a generator for a
fibonacci sequence provided that i
didn't mess up that code on the on the
live demo um and let's generate a
comment and see what the model oh there
we go quick response from our from our
optimize inference api and we see um
fibonacci sequence generator um so that
wraps up our somewhat long uh live code
demo um but hopefully it's clear how
simple the actual portion of leveraging
the api was that was actually and you
know most of code was actually writing
the vs code extension um and so this was
just you know one one model or five
total models we've been through um of
which you can actually use with our
inference api so you can see how big the
potential
the potential is for the inference api
um one more thing i wanted to add was a
caution with the machine learning models
you know they're not they're never
foolproof it's always important to test
them um and it's always good to have an
air of caution when when thinking
something is going to be perfect it's
always good to test them
but yeah so with that in mind um i think
i think we should move on to questions
and uh 49 you want to kick that off
yeah sure before we start with the q a i
just want to give you the gift guys
so if you register today so don't be
quick uh to one of our two plans
for the inferencing pi you guys get a
100 million free input characters which
is pretty much like one thousand dollars
value so you guys should register today
and with that in mind uh we will start
with the q a sessions so we we had a lot
of cool questions
um one idol really liked is uh from
antonio he said that uh sometimes he
writes uh cuts from
it he copies cut python code from the
books and various misspellings so you
wanna know if there is something like a
spell checker for code
i mean something we could do with the
inference api
yeah yeah i mean i would think so it
seems like a like a i mean you can
imagine if we can generate documentation
from code if we've got models that can
generate code i i could see how you know
spell checking code is actually probably
an easier task um so yeah i think that's
definitely something we could accomplish
with the api given given we train the
right models
cool and uh a question from miguel uh he
want to know if there's a way to
generate paraphrases
uh to put
to generate different phrases with the
same meaning
yes yes definitely we have actually
paraphrased models available on on the
hugging face hub i really recommend you
you go check it out you can use uh the
first page i started on showing showing
off the model hub to search for for
models that are um that they do similar
things and and test them out right there
within our widgets on the on that page
um but yeah those exist you check it out
all right uh ikea want to know if
there's a limit for the inference api uh
in the example you provided like if we
have 500 lines of code written in p10
does it still work
yeah yeah so so it kind of depends um
some of the models have a limited
context you can use um so 500 lines
depending on how long each line is it
might actually run into to some issues
um with that um that being said you know
it's an active part of the field right
now is figuring out how to handle longer
pieces of text and so you know as that
advances uh hopefully hopefully we'll be
able to incorporate that at the same
speed
cool
so jeff there was a question you already
answered but i guess it's pretty
interesting for all of us
it was a question about security and
with the gdpr like can you tell us about
all data involved
yes of course uh so we use
https
and the best
security features
from our infrastructure providers
and for customers who have specific
requirements around security we're able
to address them through an enterprise
level plan things like uh log less
requests so there is no copy
of the inference request input and
output
um
and other and other uh security or data
governance uh requirements like where
the where the infrastructure is hosted
um as it relates to gdpr
all right we'll do a last question from
piotr he's asking uh
if there are any models uh in computer
vision they can perform more complex
tasks than
classification for example object
segmentation
absolutely and something i would direct
you to check out the model hub for there
is actually a few different um just
vision related tasks that are available
currently
and one of them is is is object
detection um which which goes pretty
closely related to uh
image segmentation um so definitely
check it out
all right uh
that's wraps it up uh you guys should
register today uh you know that uh you
may know that if you subscribe
uh today or you also get a very uh free
week of trial
so uh you guys should register today
just start playing with it uh you have
one thousand dollars of value to to play
with and uh hopefully uh we'll see you
as satisfied uh users of our inference
api
um
this is a wrap-up uh thanks so much
canal thanks so much jeff uh everything
will you you guys will have a link to
the replay
and thanks so much for participating
uh
so i'll hopefully see you guys next time
thanks very much
thank you it was super fun
bye everyone
bye-bye
[Music]
you